I'm Krtin.
I'm 15, and I live in Surrey in the UK.
I love playing piano,...
...spending time with friends, and most of all, I love squash.
I play as much as I can.
It's the best sport ever.
When I was younger, I had surgery on my ear...
...and since then, I've been interested in how medical science...
...can really change people's lives.
I was reading about Alzheimer's.
It's a devastating disease and it's really hard to diagnose early,...
...so I wanted to help find a solution.
After I did some research, I realized that in Alzheimer's patients,...
...certain proteins appear in the brain sooner...
...and in higher concentrations than in people who don't have the disease.
I created a solution that enters the brain with a simple injection...
...and latches onto the protein.
That allowed me to see exactly how much of the protein was there...
...and decide whether or not the patient had Alzheimer's.
I'm still so amazed that I found a way...
...to successfully diagnose Alzheimer's at an early stage.
Maybe because we're young and still learning.
We're not afraid of trying new things.
We can bring new ideas into the world,...
...and one day, I hope to see my new idea be used by doctors to save lives.